what's that you say you've been hiding
in your nuclear bunker for the last
month and haven't heard about the cares
act we'll bring you up to speed it's an
economic relief bill of historic
proportions to help soften the financial
shock wave of cope in nineteen many of
us are starting to feel the effects of
the cares Act on a personal level you
might have gotten a stimulus check or
have filed for unemployment for the
first time but lots of us are trying to
get a sense of how it's affecting the
country at large do huge government
stimulus programs actually work and who
is ultimately going to foot this bill
there's no sugarcoating it we're in a
grim economic period in history during
times like these governments have two
major tools at their disposal to keep
things from spiraling out of control
monetary policy and fiscal policy
monetary policy can be used by a
government central bank to create more
money and make borrowing easier for
example back in March the US Federal
Reserve began buying back hundreds of
billions in bonds which essentially
injected more cash into the economy it
also slashed interest rates to nearly
zero which lowered the price of loans
for people and businesses but in a
crisis simply flexing the monetary
policy isn't enough it has to be coupled
with fiscal policy this is when a
government shifts its own spending
levels to influence the economy this
looks like increases in government
spending gifts or loans authorized by
Congress the largest American fiscal
program in the last century was the New
Deal in the 1930s the federal government
spent money building roads parks and
libraries to put people back to work
another approach is to send cash
directly to people or businesses this
was done in 2008 and now if you received
a check from the government in the last
few weeks or a grant to your small
business that's
fiscal policy in action so to recap
monetary stimulus is designed to create
a more hospitable environment for its
citizens
to spend their money fiscal stimulus
means the government steps in and does
the spending itself while both of these
tools are usually used together in the
event of a crisis its fiscal stimulus
that has the most dramatic and immediate
effect it's impossible to know how
effective this version of it will be
until more time has passed thankfully we
do have the benefit of some past
examples to get a sense of how fiscal
stimulus has played out following 9/11
Congress passed a 15 billion dollar
stimulus package in loans and direct aid
to Airlines in an effort to save the
industry the results were mixed the
program did meet the goal of preventing
an industry implosion and once all loans
were repaid the Treasury posted a 300
million dollar profit however critics
point out that it wasn't an outright
success since it basically rewarded
reckless companies who got everything
they asked for and responded by laying
off thousands of employees and reducing
service we saw stimulus utilized on a
grander scale to slow the economic
freefall of 2008 when a housing crisis
ballooned into one of the worst
recessions in our country's history two
major programs rolled out first the
Troubled Asset Relief Program or tarp
created a 700 billion dollar program to
buy troubled assets from failing banks
helped the auto industry and protect
homeowners facing foreclosure
it helped study a teetering financial
system and ended in the black posting a
profit again of 15 billion dollars but
like the previous bailout it was
criticized for seeming to reward rather
than punish risky and irresponsible
behavior by Wall Street if tarp was
designed to stop the bleeding
the American Recovery and Reinvestment
Act or ARRA began the healing process
it provided 831 billion dollars to three
main programs temporary relief for
families and businesses expansion for
food assistance and unemployment
benefits and increased spending for
infrastructure and educational projects
critics at the time called the plan a
big government blank check that didn't
do enough to help the work
in class though economists today
generally agree that things would have
been much much worse without it in 2012
the Congressional Budget Office reported
the ARRA raised GDP and lowered
unemployment by creating as many as 1.7
million jobs so here we are in 2020 in
the midst of a global crisis and already
dozens of countries have rolled out
their own versions of fiscal stimulus
Italian lawmakers are working out
details on a 28 billion dollar plan to
support laid off workers and issue loans
to businesses
India's stimulus is focusing on even
more basic needs by issuing 23 billion
dollars to give food to poor families
that were locked down Germany's numbers
to date are one of the highest at a
hundred and eighty nine billion followed
by China at a hundred and sixty nine
billion but by an enormous margin the
American cares Act takes the cake in
fact our program is over twice the size
of all other countries combined this two
point three trillion dollar bill would
have been inconceivable a few short
months ago yet today the broad opinion
seems to be that it hasn't gone far
enough
case in point the 350 billion dollar
fund to help businesses maintain payroll
was exhausted in a matter of weeks
leaving millions of businesses out in
the cold now we all know there's no such
thing as a free lunch so the big
question is who's going to be
financially responsible for this 2.3
trillion dollar life raft surprise it's
us taxpayers are ultimately going to be
on the hook for this and any future
bailouts with the passage of cares the
total federal debt is now 25 trillion
technically six of that is money the
government owes itself so 19 trillion is
a more commonly used figure for context
our country's entire GDP was 21 point
seven trillion for 2019 so what are the
possible consequences for a country
racking up such an enormous amount of
debt it's been long-held economic wisdom
that a country should avoid exceeding
90% of its GDP in debt so that their
growth doesn't get crushed under the
weight of debt payment
before the stimulus bill America was
clocking around 87% but in the last few
decades economists are increasingly
questioning this idea they look at the
fact that last fiscal year interest
payments tracked around 1.7 percent of
GDP while back in 1999 they were 3
percent of GDP based off those numbers
we could potentially have 50 trillion
dollars in debt and still keep the
interest from racking up but that's just
interest how do we pay back the
principal the hard truth is just like a
family household we're either going to
have to cut spending or raise income
yeah that means taxes realistically it
would have to be a mix of both simply
cutting your way out of this would
require a 25% decrease in federal
spending which is more than the budget
of the entire US military a number so
extreme it would probably cause another
recession which would require more
stimulus etc you know where this is
going and a tax hike in the near future
would be very unpopular
yikes we're doomed surprisingly probably
not experts believe that the US could
continue to take on even more debt as
long as inflation stays low thankfully
according to William Gale a fellow at
the Brookings Institute there are
powerful forces keeping inflation low
like technological advances and
globalization things that are unlikely
to disappear as long as GDP is able to
grow faster than interest payments you
should be okay
so the answer to does economic stimulus
work depends on how you define success
recent versions have left large groups
out in the cold and have been slow to
turn things around
but in hindsight the majority of
economic experts believe they are
necessary and while imperfect keep bad
situations from getting much worse these
programs aren't free and we will end up
paying the bill with slower economic
growth in the future
stimulants in finance and medicine have
limited benefits that D
with use but just like an emergency
stimulant given by a doctor they can be
the difference between life and death
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]